we're following a potential breakthrough
into what may be causing severe lung
illnesses possibly linked to marijuana
vaping government health investigators
say they discovered a chemical in the
products that may be to blame the CDC
reported more than 200 cases of severe
respiratory diseases potentially linked
to vaping the agency confirms at least
one person has died from vaping related
illnesses Dean Reynolds is in
Libertyville Illinois with one teenagers
near-death experience Dean what do we
know about this chemical good morning
well the chemical in question is an oil
derived from vitamin E which
investigators found in samples of
marijuana vaping products from patients
all over the country who got sick after
vaping and it's another sign of the
potential risk from vaping unknown or
uncertain substances my lungs are like a
70 volts at a Morgan Raider of Gurnee
Illinois has been hospitalized since
last week he says he vaped with THC the
primary ingredient of marijuana how do
you get that you know THC basically off
the streets I guess not like a drug
dealer you're buying it off the street
from some guy that you don't really know
in retrospect do you think that was kind
of dumb yeah when you're addicted like
that I don't think that goes through
your mind soon after Adam became
feverish started vomiting and was
gasping for breath his mother Polly
drove him to the hospital where he went
straight to intensive care it's probably
every parent's nightmare and we couldn't
make Adam better did you ever think that
your son might die yes because we were
told he would have Adam told us he'd
been vaping for about two years to get
the buzz from nicotine and then the high
from marijuana can you get a deep breath
I can but most of the time it ends up in
a call do you regret this of course yeah
my lungs will never be the same this is
what your x-ray looked like Adams
pulmonologist dr. Stephen Amesbury were
that the current crisis may be only the
beginning do you have any doubt in your
mind that vaping is responsible for this
there doesn't seem to be anything else
turning up in these cases we look for
the other potential causes but we
haven't been able to find anything else
and coincidentally all these people have
been vaping now contaminants and vaping
products counterfeit vaping products
like the one used by Adam are of
interest to health officials
investigating these illnesses and while
the potential link to the vitamin E oil
is important the FDA says much more
testing is needed to get at the cause of
what's making people sick Tony
interesting to see the reporting shift
from ISA Gretz to what are effectively e
joints Dean thank you very much